Artem Studennikov, bonjour.
Nous vous reçevons aujourd'hui pour une chaine youtube qui s'appelle ThinkerView
On voudrait avoir votre point de vue sur la géopolitique mondiale, sur l'actualité.
Comment ça va ? Comment aller vous ? Qu'est-ce qui se passe en Rusie ? Qu'est-ce qui se passe un peu partout dans le monde ?
- Bonjour, et comme d'habitude, je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
et en ma personne, l'ambassade de Russie si vous voulez, à Paris.
- Vous êtes le numéro deux de l'ambassade de Russie
- Tout à fait, c'est comme çà,
c'est mon troisième poste en France,
et depuis octobre 2015,
j'assume les responsabilités du ministre conseiller
chef de mission adjoint de l'ambassade de Russie en France.
Donc, heu... Ecoutez heu...
Comment ça va ? Vous avez dit...
Bah, globalement, évidemment, comme tout le monde répond ça va bien,
mais si on prend l'aspect
international, si on prend la situation dans le monde donc,
ça ne va pas très bien... A notre avis.
Parce que le monde
devient de plus en plus instable,
les conflits se multiplient
Heu.. La situation...
Devient de plus en plus compliquée dans plusieurs pays du monde,
mais tout d'abord, évidemment
dans cette région qui était toujours
assez compliquée,
mais aujourd'hui, elle est devenue vraiment heu...
Notre problème numéro un pour tout le monde.
C'est le proche et moyen orient.
Cette région, depuis plusieurs années déjà
est déstabilisée
et si autrefois, à l'époque,
on pouvait parler de cette crise
Arabo-Israelienne
ou Palestino-Israelienne...
Il y avait cette guerre entre Irak et Iran,
mais à part ça, la région était plus ou moins stable.
Même si nous prenons l'Afghanistan,
à l'époque de cette...
Cette entrée des forces soviétiques en Afghanistan,
Même à cette époque là,
la situation en Afghanistan était beaucoup plus stable qu'aujourd'hui.
Donc, heu... Nous constatons une crise énorme autour de la Syrie.
Une crise qui implique plusieurs pays de la région.
Nous constatons la guerre sans fin au Yemen.
La guerre oubliée par tout le monde.
Tandis que là, les pertes humanitaires,
les pertes de la population civile
se calculent déjà par des milliers et des milliers,
et tout çà, toutes ces victimes, toutes ces pertes
c'est le résultat de cette opération menée par
l'Arabie Saoudite.
Tout le monde est conscient et en même temps
tout le monde ne parle pas de ces bombardements aveugles
qui se produisent tout le temps dans cette région
de la péninsule Arabique.
Nous avons... là... la situation...
très urgente et...
très aiguë en Libye.
On a constaté la défragmentation de ce pays
après...
Après l'entrée dans le jeu
des pays occidentaux, surtout de la France et
de la Grande Bretagne,
qui ont contribué à la chute du régime de Kadhafi
mais qui n'ont pas épaulé les nouvelles autorités
depuis dans la reconstruction de la Libye.
Donc, en résultat, nous avons...
Un chaos.
Evidemment, aujourd'hui, la société internationale
fait beaucoup pour essayer
de prendre les choses en main
et pour aider le gouvernement provisoire
de prendre sous leur contrôle la situation dans le pays
mais vous savez très bien qu'il y a un facteur
des "ducadistes" internationaux,
il y a le facteur de cette défragmentation du pays,
de ce conflit larvé entre Tobrouk et Tripoli.
Donc la situation est très très compliquée dans cette région.
Et en même temps,
cette déstabilisation de la Libye,
a renforcé les forces radicales,
les forces extrémistes,
dans certaines régions de l'Afrique Equatoriale.
Je parle...
Je parle du Mali, du Nigéria, du Cameroun du Tchad
avec cette organisation qui est rattachée à Al Qaïda
Boko Haram, justement.
Donc vous voyez, heu...
Cette instabilité dans la région
du proche et moyen orient
a déjà des conséquences pour des régions beaucoup plus éloignées.
Je n'ai pas évoqué, mais il faut le faire,
les tensions entre l'Arabie Saoudite et l'Iran.
En réalité, c'est presque la guerre par procuration
ce que nous voyons au Yemen.
- Par proxy ?
- Par proxy, justement.
C'est un pays où se heurtent
les intérêts de l'Arabie Saoudite Sunite
et de l'Iran Chiite.
Il ne faut pas oublier le Liban
qui est toujours... Où la situation reste très fragile,
à cause de cette crise politique interne sans fin,
l'absence du président.
Nous devons évidemment évoquer l'Afghanistan
où les forces des talibans
ont pris sous leur contrôle Kunduz
et maintenant l'armée se bat pour reprendre
cette ville très importante en Afghanistan.
Mais toutes ces situations nous démontrent
combien la situation est compliquée en Afghanistan
La France, avec les autres partenaires de la coalition
se prépare à épauler les forces Irakiennes à reprendre
Mossoul
Le plus grand... Un des plus grands pays de l'Irak
pris par
l'Etat Islamique, par Daesh
Donc vous voyez, nous pouvons continuer à parler
de tous ces problèmes innombrables de la région
qui déstabilisent non seulement la région,
mais qui créent des tensions à l'échelle mondiale.
- Je voudrais que l'on aborde l'aspect de déstabilisation
par des facteurs extérieurs, par proxy.
On entend dire qu'il y a 89 nationalités de djihadistes en Syrie.
Quel est votre point de vue ?
Quels sont leurs modes de financement ?
Et qui tire les ficelles ?
- Là...
Nous connaissons ce problème
selon notre propre expérience, parce que
on a déjà rencontré ce phénomène
des djihadistes étrangers en Tchétchénie.
Surtout lors de la deuxième opération anti-terroriste en Tchétchénie.
Parce que là, on a rencontré
pas mal de gens de ce type là
Et heu...
Certains, parmi eux
ont occupé une place importante
dans le système hiérarchique
du commandement
des rebelles, des terroristes
en Tchétchénie.
Donc...
Pour nous, ce n'est pas
notre première expérience.
Mais, effectivement, ce phénomène
en série a connu vraiment
un grand essor, un grand succès si l'on peut dire
parce que, selon notre
estimation,
une grande partie des gens
armés qui luttent aujourd'hui contre
le gouvernement de Damas,
je ne peux pas vous donner le pourcentage, mais
en tous cas, il s'agit de dizaines de pourcents.
Ce sont des étrangers, venus de différents coins du monde
pour combattre pour cette cause
du Daesh, de l'Etat Islamique
pour la création d'un khalifat
mondial, parce que initialement vous savez que
cette organisation s'appelait
Etat Islamique du Levant et du Liban
Heu... De Syrie et du Levant.
C'est à dire...
Il se proposait de créer un khalifat sur le territoire
assez limité.
Mais après, ils ont changé d'avis, ils ont
re-batisé leur mouvement
en le nommant
tout simplement l'Etat Islamique
tout en comprenant que
la région limitée, ce n'est pas suffisant
Ce n'est pas suffisant, il faut tout simplement créer
un khalifat, un Etat Islamique à l'échelle mondiale.
Et c'était la raison
de notre décision
assez
difficile à prendre
de venir en force en Syrie, pour
soutenir
le gouvernement légitime de ce pays
pour éviter l'effondrement total
de l'Etat Syrien
et pour ne pas créer
la base pour
l'élargissement
d'une zone de contrôle
de l'Etat Islamique sur toute la région.
Parce que nous sommes profondément persuadés
que l'opposition soit disant modérée
Syrienne, qui d'ailleurs existe.
Je pense que c'est une réalité.
Mais nous sommes profondément persuadés que...
les capacités de cette opposition modérée
est incomparable avec les capacités de l'Etat Islamique,
et en cas de l'effondrement de l'Etat Syrien,
cette opposition modérée serait
rasée de la carte politique de Syrie
par le mouvement de l'Etat Islamique,
par le mouvement de Daesh.
Et après, c'est le Liban,
après c'est l'Arabie Saoudite,
après c'est l'Egypte,
où la situation reste aussi très très fragile.
Donc, c'état la raison de notre
implication dans le conflit Syrien
aux côtés de l'armée de Bachar El Assad.
Justement parce que
nous savons très bien que
l'opposition armée radicale et non radicale,
est soutenue par les sponsors étrangers
- Quels sont les sponsors ?
- Ecoutez, nous avons plusieurs informations,
qui émanent de différentes sources,
que le soutien provient de certains pays du Golf.
- Lesquels ?
- Ecoutez, j'aimerais bien ne pas citer ces pays.
Parce que vous comprenez très bien qu'il faut donner des preuves concrètes.
Je pense que...
Les services, les autorités compétentes en France,
aux Etats Unis et en Russies, possèdent de telles informations.
Mais là, je ne veux pas citer les pays.
Vous les connaissez très bien, tous ces pays.
Et les internautes qui suivent sur internet
ont eu pas mal d'informations, ont eu pas mal de...
pas mal de rumeurs, pas mal d'informations plus ou moins...
convaincantes, concernant ce sujet.
Mais nous comprenons très bien
que toutes ces armes, tout ce financement,
toutes ces munitions
ne peuvent pas parvenir du ciel.
Evidemment, il y a des trophées de guerre,
mais il y a un soutien logistique
qui...
arrive, qui est arrivé dès le début de cette
guerre civile en Syrie.
Pour nous, c'est un des facteurs qui nous a fait prendre
cette décision, comme je vous l'ai dit, difficile à prendre
parce que, après notre expérience en Afghanistan,
envoyer nos troupes, envoyer nos pilotes
à des centaines... à des milliers de kilomètres de la Russie, en Syrie,
c'est un risque.
Mais c'est un risque pour nous raisonnable
parce que il ne faut pas oublier que
ce qu'il se passe en Syrie se trouve...
Ou plutôt, la Syrie se trouve à 800 kilomètres
de la frontière Russe.
Et pour nous, la lutte contre l'Etat Islamique en Syrie
signifie la lutte contre les futurs djhiadistes
qui pourraient un jour venir...
Déstabiliser les pays limitrophes
de la Russie. C'est à dire les pays de l'Asie centrale
aussi bien que la Russie comme telle.
- On a vu récemment
la crise se polariser avec
vraiment, une augmentation des tensions avec la Syrie
entre les Etats Unis et la Russie.
La question que je vais vous poser,
qui est très directe :
Est-ce que vous êtes en train de vous préparer à un conflit ouvert nucléaire avec les Etats Unis ?
Bien sur que non.
Moi, je disais, heu.. Je ne me souviens plus si j'ai...
évoqué ce sujet lors de
ma précédente...
visite chez vous.
Mais moi, je pense que c'est un sujet tabou.
Nous tous nous devons...
bien comprendre que
cette option est absolument impossible.
- Est-ce qu'elle est envisageable ?
- Il ne faut pas même envisager cette option.
Non, il ne faut pas le faire.
Parce que là,
nous n'avons aucune raison de parler de cette
option horrible.
Je refuse en tous cas de...
d'évoquer et d'analyser
l'éventualité de cette
tournure des choses.
Mais, mais, effectivement,
les tensions ont beaucoup monté depuis
quelque temps entre la Russie et les Etats Unis.
Après...
Après la fin de ce cesser le feu
qui a été le résultat de longues
tractations, de longues négociations entre
les chefs de la diplomatie Russe et Américaine.
- Nous avons annoncé votre venue sur internet depuis mercredi.
D'ailleurs, merci d'avoir répondu aussi vite à notre sollicitation.
Les internautes nous ont fait remonter énormément de coupures de presse Russe,
tant Russes, qu'Anglaises et Américaines.
J'ai pu voir passer devant mes yeux des exercices militaires en Russie,
qui engageraient 40 millions de civiles,
200 ou 300 mille personnels militaires
- 40 millions de civiles ?
- Oui.
- En quelle forme ?
- Participation d'exercice de frappe sur votre territoire.
- Puis, j'ai vu...
Passez des papiers, d'ailleurs Russia today
a posté, il y a pas loin d'une demi-heure,
que les déclarations de généraux américains qui
expliquaient, si vous voulez que je vous donne exactement le titre :
qui expliquaient que les généraux américains :
un conflit extrêmement meurtrier avec la Russie est quasiment certain.
- Mmm... Ecoutez. Là, heu...
Je ne peux pas commenter les paroles des généraux américains.
Les généraux Russes ne parlent pas de cette
éventualité.
Les généraux Russes préviennent que
nous avons suffisamment de moyens en Syrie,
pour riposter au cas où.
Mais nous avons ces moyens depuis le début de notre opération en Syrie.
Le conflit, ou plutôt,
les incidents
sont toujours possibles
et voilà pourquoi, même après l'arrêt
des négociations entre la Russie et les Etats Unis sur...
- Le plutonium ?
- Comment ?
- Sur le plutonium ?
- Non ! Non, non.
Là, il n'y avait pas de négociation, il y avait un traité.
Mais, non, je parle de la Syrie.
L'arrêt des négociations, de cet échange
continu entre les deux ministères des affaires étrangères
et les deux ministères de la défense
ne signifie pas l'arrêt
des contacts entre les militaires
pour assurer le déconflicting, la déconflictation.
dans le cadre de...
des agréments sur le... Sur la déconflictation.
C'est à dire : et les américains et les russes comprennent très bien que
la situation où
l'aviation de deux pays
est présente dans le ciel syrien.
Parce que les américains mènent leur propre opération anti-terroristes,
et la Russie effectue sa propre opération anti-terroriste
à côté du gouvernement légitime syrien.
Donc, la présence de deux aviations dans le ciel
de la Syrie,
demande un contact permanent entre les militaires,
pour éviter les incidents,
les conflits,
pour assurer cette déconflictation.
Et je voudrais bien mettre l'accent sur ce fait.
Donc, d'abord, on continue à parler avec les américains en principe sur la Syrie.
Et nos deux ministres des affaires étrangères
se sont déjà échangé des coups de fil après
l'annonce par les autorités américaines
de l'arrêt de ces contacts sur
le cesser le feu.
Donc, nous continuons à parler avec les américains.
Et les militaires continuent à se contacter pour éviter
justement, les accrochages,
par erreur
les bavures, etc...
- C'est une erreur que votre ambassade en Syrie ait été bombardée ?
- Non, selon notre avis,
c'était une action
préparée et effectuée par
Jabhat Al Nusra qui a changé un petit peu son nom,
son étiquette, mais pas...
- Le fait que les Etats Unis bloquent la condamnation à l'ONU.
Qu'est-ce que cela vous a fait ?
Bien écoutez, pour nous cela reflète
la politique ambigüe des Etats Unis,
la politique du double standard.
Les Etats Unis ont démontrés une nouvelle fois.
qu'ils ont des relations très ambivalentes ambivalentes
à l'égard de nos positions radicales syriennes.
Oui, c'est dommage. C'est dommage mais ce n'est pas pour la première fois.
On espérait convaincre les américains de
soutenir cette résolution
au bout de cette déclaration
qui met juste l'accent sur cette nécessité
de respecter la convention de Vienne
et qui souligne
le statut spécifique des ambassades
dans tout le monde y compris en Syrie
qui n'ont pas soutenu notre projet,
ou plutôt qui ont voulu introduire certaines dispositions
qui n'étaient pas acceptables pour la partie Russe
et voilà pourquoi...
- Lesquelles ?
- Sur la responsabilité de la Russie
pour ce regain des tensions en Syrie.
Voilà. Pour dire, si vous voulez, que
c'est notre tort, que c'est notre responsabilité,
le fait que l'ambassade de Russie a été bombardée
c'est le résultat des démarches des activités Russes en Syrie.
Voilà. C'était l'idée américaine.
Tandis que pour nous ce n'était pas acceptable, on voulait
juste accuser l'attaque contre la représentation diplomatique.
Parce que on ne sait jamais,
dans n'importe quel pays du monde,
n'importe quelle représentation diplomatique
pourrait être attaquée et si nous
ne réagissons pas,
à ce type d'action,
heu... Cela peut amener à des...
A des choses inacceptables.
- Quand vote commandement en Syrie
a annoncé qu'il abattrait tout avion et tout missile
en direction de Bacha El Assad, de son armée,
comment les américains ont perçu çà ?
Maintenant que vous avez mis des S 300 et des S 400, je crois bien...
- Voilà, justement, je voulais... Ce que j'ai dit déjà,
des S 400 étaient présents sur le sol syrien
dès le début de l'opération
ou en tout cas très rapidement après le début de l'opération.
Et les S300 étaient arrivés avec l'aviation russe,
pour assurer...
- La protection de
- La protection de notre base. Voilà.
Ecoutez ! Oui...
On a prévenu
tous les pays impliqués dans le conflit,
dans la situation en Syrie, dans le conflit syrien, que
les frappes contre
l'armée
syrienne, contre
le gouvernement
légitime syrien,
auront des conséquences néfastes pour
pour la région et pour la Syrie.
En ce qui concerne la pratique,
j'espère que personne ne va
aller vers l'aggravation de la situation.
J'espère que
nous allons continuer ensemble des efforts
conjoints pour essayer de trouver
la solution, pour essayer de
baisser les tensions
et la Russie se prononce pour
pour la continuation
des pourparlers sur la Syrie
entre les acteurs clé
et entre
les forces syriennes.
Y compris le gouvernement et
les différentes branches de l'opposition.
Sauf, evidemment
les groupes reconnus comme terroristes
par l'organisation des nations unies.
- La France,
dans la région,
quel est votre regard sur la diplomatie française ?
Vous voyez que...
Vous avez vu, évidemment que
le ministre des affaires étrangères,
monsieur Ayrault,
a été accueilli à Moscou par
par monsieur Lavrov, par notre ministre des affaires étrangères.
C'est une visite éclair et nous avons accepté immédiatement après
la demande de nos partenaires français,
donc vous voyez que
le dialogue très dense
continue.
Et ici, à Paris, nous, en tant que l'ambassade,
nous sommes en contact permanent avec nos partenaires
et collègues français.
A l'ONU aussi, et on travaille
entre les représentations permanentes
de la Russie et de la France à New York.
Partout nous parlons, partout nous échangeons
des idées de nos évaluations des choses.
Mais, on constate que
la politique française n'a pas beaucoup bougé depuis le début du conflit.
La France
met
toujours sur le départ
de Bachar Al Assad
sans réfléchir à l'avenir
de la Syrie dans cette situation là.
Par contre, l'approche française a évolué.
En quelques sortes. Parce que
initialement, la France exigeait le départ immédiat de Bachar Al Assad.
Aujourd'hui,
ce n'est pas une condition préalable pour le début des
négociations entre...
Le début de ce dialogue inter syrien.
Non, aujourd'hui la France reconnait que Bachar Al Assad
peut rester au pouvoir
en tous cas au début de ces pour parler et pendant ces pour parler.
Mais, Paris exige toujours
le départ de Bachar Al Assad.
Nos partenaires français, pour l'heure actuelle,
ne peuvent pas imaginer que Bachar Al Assad
pourrait prendre part aux élections
présidentielles, organisée
conformément
à l'accord entre toutes les forces syriennes.
De ce point de vue, Paris reste sur le même
sur la même position.
Mais en même temps, nous partageons avec la France
une idée sur la Syrie du futur
sur la Syrie de l'avenir,
sur la Syrie
unifiée
la Syrie qui respecte toutes les minorités
ethniques et toutes les confessions religieuses.
Sur la Syrie démocratique et laïque.
Notre analyse ou plutôt nos souhaits
sont les mêmes.
Nos approches sont différentes.
Comment aboutir à cette Syrie.
Comment aboutir à la fin des hostilités
et à la fin de la guerre civile.
Là, effectivement, il est à reconnaître, ce n'est pas un secret,
nos approches sont très différentes.
- On a... Du moins, la presse occidentale
et l'intelligentsia française
ont beaucoup reproché à la Russie
ce qui ce passe à Alep
Quelle est votre vision
de ce qui ce passe à Alep ?
Est-ce que c'est un blitzkrieg ?
Est-ce que c'est un bombardement total et aveugle ?
Ou est-ce que vous suspectez l'injection de
de l'Etat Islamique à travers les fameux casques blancs
syriens ? Quelle est votre lecture ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Ecoutez heu...
Pour nous, ce qui ce passe à Alep aujourd'hui
c'est le résultat
des activités
des groupes terroristes infiltrés dans la ville
et qui aujourd'hui,
en réalité contrôlent cette partie d'Alep.
Parce que ce sont les combattants
de Jafrat Al Nusra
qui tiennent en main
la situation dans cette ville là.
Et malheureusement, le problème c'est que
nos partenaires américains
n'ont pas réussi ce qu'ils ont promis de faire
depuis des mois déjà.
Séparer
les milices
de l'opposition modérée
les troupes, les unités de l'opposition
modérée
des unités,
des troupes, qui appartiennent
à cette organisation de Jafrat Al Nusra.
Cà, c'est le problème
primordial, le problème crucial.
Nous avons demandé
pendant des mois et des mois à nos partenaires américains
de respecter leur partie des promesses.
Parce que nous avons fait tout ce que nous pouvions
faire avec nos partenaires syriens.
On a demandé à nos partenaires syriens
d'arrêter les combats, d'arrêter les hostilités
et la trêve a duré quelques temps.
Pendant
la durée de cette
nouvelle trêve
l'opposition
modérée et radicale
qui c'est mélangée déjà
à Alep,
a profité de cette pause
pour renforcer ses positions.
Tout en continuant à attaquer
Alep est, où se trouve... Pardon !
Alep ouest qui se trouve sous contrôle du gouvernement syrien
en attaquant des positions des troupes syriennes
et en renforçant ses positions
partout dans la région.
Dans ce contexte, l'armée syrienne
est, sans cette...
Sans la mise en pratique de cette promesse américaine
de séparer les troupes des radicaux
et des modérés
l'armée syrienne a été obligée de rompre
d'arrêter le cesser le feu
et de riposter.
Le résultat de cette riposte,
c'est l'offensive effectuée aujourd'hui par
l'armée syrienne à Alep.
En ce qui concerne l'utilisation de l'aviation.
Ecoutez.
Je peux parler pour l'aviation russe.
Toutes les frappes que nous effectuons
sont bien ciblées.
Cà c'est notre position de principe.
Nous travaillons...
L'aviation Russe travaille
uniquement sur les sites, sur les cibles
qui ont été reconnues comme
comme cibles appartenant...
comme des cibles légitimes.
Comme des cibles, comme des positions des
forces de Jafrat Al Nusra,
comme des points de commandement,
comme des
stocks de munition, etc...
Telle est notre position.
- Si vous identifiez un hôpital, ou l'armée syrienne identifie un hôpital
comme un centre de commandement
ou une cache terroriste
est-ce que vous rasez l'hôpital ?
Ecoutez, je ne suis pas militaire et je ne suis pas sur le terrain.
Je n'ai pas toute l'information dans sa généralité.
Mais il faut être réaliste. Nous sommes des réalistes.
Pendant la guerre,
tout peut arriver. Il y a des bavures.
Vous savez très bien que l'armée américaine
a bombardé les troupes syriennes
tuant 62 personnes,
et blessant encore une centaine de personnes.
C'est une bavure.
Les bavures sont possibles.
Surtout heu... Mais quand je parle de l'aviation
Russe, je souligne,
chaque frappe est bien préparée.
Chaque frappe est effectuée à la base des informations
que nous recevons par tous les moyens possibles,
en utilisant tous les moyens de renseignements
Donc, bien sûr nous voulons faire tout pour minimiser
les pertes chez les civils.
Je ne peux pas exclure que
ces pertes soient possibles.
Mais, en même temps,
quand même, il y a beaucoup de propagande
dans le contexte
actuel à Alep.
Ecoutez... Humm...
Vraiment...
Personne ne parle pas de la situation au Yemen
où l'aviation
de l'Arabie Saoudite et de ses aliés
par cette coalition "antirussite"
bombarde chaque jour ou presque
les différents coins du Yemen
en tuant des centaines et des centaines de civils.
(thinkerview) Il y a deux poids deux mesures ?
- En bombardant des hôpitaux,
des fêtes de mariage,
(thinkerview) Des écoles
- Tout ce que vous voulez
Personne ne parle pas de cette situation
absolument scandaleuse.
- La Libye ?
- La Libye, bon la Libye a été bombardée il y a déjà un bon moment, mais...
La Libye, c'est plutôt un exemple de ce qui peut arriver avec un pays
si l'ingérence
de l'extérieur
n'est pas accompagnée par...
Par le concours politique au redressement
économique et politique de ce pays.
- Comment vous expliquez que la presse française et occidentale ne
ne se polarise que sur la Syrie et
oublie le Yemen ?
- Ecoutez
Je ne peux pas dire que le Yemen est oublié
De temps en temps, effectivement
il y a des articles qui apparaissent
dans tous les grands masse médias français
Mais, oui, c'est... Ecoutez
c'est de la politique hum...
C'est la réalité de notre temps. Oui.
Tous les regards sont concentrés sur la Syrie.
Parce que la Syrie, c'est un pays plus important,
plus peuplé, au centre de la région
déjà très difficile
et le Yemen, il est quelque part ailleurs, il est...
c'est une région plus éloignée peut-être
c'est cela qui peut expliquer la situation.
Par contre, effectivement, je pense que...
cette...
critique...
à l'égard de la Russie
parfois n'est pas très objective
et très partielle.
- Je voudrais qu'on change un petit peu de région du monde;
J'aimerais que l'on aborde les questions des troupes de l'OTAN
à la frontière Russe.
Sur internet on a vu depuis un certain temps
des convois de trains remplis de chars
aux couleurs forêt verte,
pas aux couleurs du désert,
se dirigeant un peu vers vous.
Comment vous percevez cela ?
- Heumm écoutez, là, oui ! Tout ce qui concerne l'OTAN...
Je pense qu'il faut examiner ces situations heumm...
dans toute sa complexité, et il faut commencer
par les évévenements du début des années 90.
Heum...
Dans les années 90, quand
le régime politique
en Union Soviétique
a changé de façon spectaculaire, ou plutôt
l'Union Soviétique a disparu,
et la fédération
de Russie en quelques sortes a pris sa place,
en tous cas, l'armée soviétique
qui avait ses bases et qui était
stationnée
dans certains pays de l'Europe
de... de l'Est,
cette armée soviétique est devenue l'armée russe.
Et heum...
Cette armée a été évacuée dans les meilleurs conditions
et dans le meilleur délai, peut-être même.
Leur départ des pays de l'Europe de l'est était
mal préparé chez nous.
Parfois les soldats et les officiers russes on été
obligés de passer plusieurs mois dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles parce que les bases n'ont pas été préparées
en Russie
Mais on a fait tout cela parce que c'était la période
c'était l'époque des illusions,
l'époque du romantisme politique,
l'époque quand on était
persuadés que le monde change
et heum... que heum...
notre prise de position, nos décisions politiques
seront appréciées à leur juste titre
par nos partenaires occidentaux.
Il faut dire que autrefois, à l'époque,
au moment de la pérétroïka,
au moment de ce rapprochement entre l'occident
et l'Union Soviétique,
au moment des rencontre de Gorbatchev avec
ses homologues occidentaux,
on lui a promis
de ne pas élargir l'OTAN
après le départ des troupes soviétiques.
Par exemple de la République Démocratique d'Allemagne,
en vue d'une réunification avec
la République Fédérale Allemande.
Rien n'a été signé.
Rien n'a été promis
dans les lettres ou dans les documents.
Mais les paroles ont été prononcées
et il y a pas mal de témoins qui
confirment que ces promesses ont été faites.
- C'est important pour un Russe une parole.
- Oui. Oui.
Tout cela je suis d'accord avec vous mais
je pense que comme disent les français "c'est un homme de parole".
Donc...
- Un homme sans parole est un homme qui ne vaut rien.
Justement.
Et, voilà, Gorbatchev
a cru. Parce que je pense que...
Et je me souviens très bien de cette période là.
Vraiment, c'était le temps des belles illusions.
Et c'était un très bon temps parce que
effectivement, après cette longue période
de la fermeture, on a levé ce rideau de fer,
on a fait des frontières transparentes,
et on attendait des pas
réciproques du côté de nos partenaires occidentaux.
Qu'est-ce que nous avons vu en réponse ?
Elargissement de l'OTAN
Elargissement qui ne s'arrête pas.
Qui ne s'arrête pas aujourd'hui.
On a vu d'abord les pays de l'Europe de...
certains de l'Europe de l'Est
entrer à l'OTAN.
Les pays de l'ex Union Soviétique
qui ont des frontières communes avec
la Russie actuelle.
On a vu les tentatives de faire entrer dans l'Otan
certains pays qui...
qui faisaient partie même de la communauté des états indépendants.
CIE. C'est à dire, la Géorgie, l'Ukraine.
On parle de la Moldavie aussi.
Donc tout cela a été très mal perçu par la population Russe.
Parce que
ce n'est pas la Russie qui s'approche aujourd'hui des frontières de l'OTAN
Mais c'est l'OTAN qui se rapproche des frontières de la Russie.
Vous savez. Peut-être vous savez que
en 1994
on a signé un accord fondateur.
Un acte fondateur.
Entre la Russie et l'OTAN
qui prévoyait la création
de cet institut comme
Conseil Russie - OTAN
qui devrait être
un site de dialogue et d'échange
dans tout état de choses
dans toutes situations et surtout dans la situation
de crise.
On est tombés d'accord avec
l'OTAN que l'OTAN ne déploie pas
les forces considérables
à la frontière de la Russie.
- Il y a eu des exercices de l'OTAN récemment
Donc plusieurs choses ont été prévues.
Mais avec du temps, sous différents prétextes,
sous prétexte de cette fameuse agressivité Russe,
l'OTAN a pris la décision
de déployer
quatre bataillons
dans les trois pays baltes
Lettonie, Estonie et Lituanie, et en Pologne
En même temps, parallèlement,
l'OTAN construit
le système anti-missile
qui a été pensé comme...
comme un système
défensif contre les pays heum...
"Feld States"
- Oui. Les pays effondrés ou en faillite
- Oui, les pays effondrés ou les pays irresponsables.
On parlait de l'Iran, on parlait de la Corée du Nord,
on parlait des terroristes, des groupes terroristes et
groupe "hors état".
Mais nos experts militaires, nos experts techniques
ont des soupçons
qui sont bien fondés
sur le fait que ce système anti-missiles
pourrait être dirigé
contre les intérêts stratégiques
de la fédération de Russie.
C'est à dire contre
les forces stratégiques de la fédération de Russie.
Dans la complexité... Si nous prenons la situation dans leur...
Dans... Voilà ! Dans cette complexité,
dans cette généralité, nous voyons que
Les hommes politiques russes et la population russe
ont tout pour être pessimistes.
L'infrastructure militaire de l'OTAN
s'approche de la frontière Russe.
Et les manoeuvres
que vous avez évoqué, c'est juste une partie de
cette tendance
qui nous inquiète beaucoup parce que
l'OTAN, quand même, ce n'est pas une organisation
avec des buts non lucratifs,
ce n'est pas une organisation humanitaire.
C'est le bloc militaire le plus puissant
dans l'histoire de l'humanité.
C'est un bloc militaire qui possède
tout un éventail des armes modernes,
des armes nucléaires,
Et quand on nous dit que
l'élargissement de l'OTAN n'est pas dirigé contre la Russie,
cela nous laisse quand même
perplexes.
- En début de semaine dernière, on a vu
deux bombardiers black jack s'approcher
des côtes bretonnes
puis des côtes anglaises.
Des beaux avions d'ailleurs.
C'était une petite promenade de santé ?
C'était pour dire bonjour ?
Vous étiez en train de faire une petite livraison ?
- Oui. Oui. Oui. Je comprends votre...
- Vous comprenez ma question.
- Je comprends votre ironie.
Ecoutez. C'est la pratique courante.
La pratique absolument normale.
Jamais les avions russes
ne franchissent
les...
Les espaces aériens des pays étrangers.
Tous les vols sont effectués dans les couloirs internationaux.
Tous les vols sont effectués
dans les airs internationaux.
- Sans transpondeur ?
- dans les espaces internationaux.
Sans transporter je pense...
- Sans transpondeur ?
- Ah transpondeur !? Ecoutez çà c'est une bonne question parce que
nous avons déjà proposé à nos partenaires de l'OTAN
d'examiner ensemble
toutes les questions qui concernent les vols
dans les régions de la mer Baltique. Pour commencer.
Parce que là, non uniquement les avions
Russes, mais aussi les avions de l'OTAN
survolent sans transpondeur.
Nous avons proposé
d'examiner ensemble
comment régler cette affaire
et tomber d'accord sur
les vols avec transpondeur mais
pour çà, il faut travailler, il faut se réunir et
il faut évoquer cette éventualité.
Il faut que les experts et les cadres techniques,
les spécialistes techniques
se mettent à la table ronde et
qu'ils se parlent.
Nous sommes ouverts
à... heum...
Cette déconflictation dans la région de la mer Baltique
et nous avons informé l'OTAN
de notre disponibilité.
Aujourd'hui on attend la réponse.
Mais, je répète, c'était l'initiative Russe,
compte tenu des préoccupations
de nos partenaires occidentaux et de l'OTAN.
Nous avons manifesté notre bonne volonté.
Nous avons dit que nous sommes prêts à discuter ce sujet.
Par contre,
la Russie, comme tous les autres pays,
a le droit
d'effectuer les vols militaires
en pleine conformité avec
le droit international,
les règles internationales
des vols.
Et je vous assure que nous respectons
toutes ces règles et toutes nos obligations internationales.
Par contre,
oui, certains pays...
de l'OTAN
s'énervent
et s'inquiètent quand ils voient les avions russes
qui ne franchissent pas leur espace aérien, mais qui volent
à quelque... Je ne sais pas...
- Cent kilomètres
- Cent kilomètres ? Cent... Quelques dizaines ou cent kilomètres.
Ecoutez. Cà, c'est le droit des pays de l'OTAN de
lever leur aviation pour accompagner les avions russes.
Je souligne :
tout ce que nous faisons dans les airs
est conforme au droit international.
- Vos deux bombardiers n'étaient pas escortés
d'intercepteurs.
Quand vos bombardiers se sont fait
escorter en dehors
de... En dehors de rien du tout d'ailleurs.
Parce que vous n'étiez pas dans l'espace aérien français.
Dans ces cas là, est-ce que notre ministre
vous appelle ? Est-ce que votre ministre
nous appelle ?
- Ecoutez. Heum...
Nous avons des appareils
militaires auprès des ambassades.
Il y a un appareil militaire auprès de l'ambassade de France,
il y a un appareil militaire
auprès de l'ambassade de Russie.
Les contacts entre les militaires existent.
Techniquement, vraiment, je ne sais pas
comment cela fonctionne dans cet état de choses.
Mais même les pilotes, ils sont munis de radios.
Ils sont toujours en contact avec
les services techniques sur le sol
Voilà ! C'est ce que je peux vous dire.
En tous cas, à ma connaissance,
même les autorités militaires françaises ont
reconnu que les avions russes
n'ont pas franchi l'espace aérien français.
Il était à côté et peut-être
les avions militaires français
n'étaient pas loin pour observer.
C'est la pratique normale
entre les militaires de tous les pays.
- Est-ce que je peux vous poser
une question indiscrète ?
Est-ce que ces avions étaient chargés ?
- Je ne peux pas vous répondre. Je ne sais pas.
Je ne pense pas.
- On va arriver sur la fin de notre interview.
Comme d'habitude,
on finit par une question pour les jeunes générations
du moins, un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Avant cette question, est-ce que vous
voyez quelque chose à ajouter ?
Est-ce que vous avez des question à nous poser ?
- Ecoutez heum...
J'ai plusieurs questions à vous poser.
Mais je pense que le format de notre émission
prévoit au contraire vos questions
adressées à moi-même.
Non, mais écoutez. Ce serait intéressant
pour moi de voir
quelle était votre appréciation
des tendances générales
aujourd'hui en Europe et dans le monde.
Est-ce que vous partagez les peurs
de cette nouvelle guerre froide
de laquelle on parle ?
Oui, ce serait intéressant de savoir
quelle était votre appréciation
du comportement
des pays occidentaux en Syrie.
Parce que plusieurs pays sont impliqués dans...
On été impliqués dans ce conflit là.
Donc, les questions sont innombrables, évidemment.
Mais je pense que nous aurons
l'opportunité d'échanger
et de parler.
Voilà pourquoi, pour nous,
le dialogue, les contacts entre les gens
les contacts entre les civils,
les société civiles,
c'est très important.
Voilà pourquoi nous soutenons
les échanges décentralisé,
comme on dit,
des échanges entre les régions
de nos deux pays
qui continuent malgré toutes les complexités
toutes les... toute cette conjoncture
internationale, pas très propice
au développement des relations au niveau
inter-étatique.
Mais les contacts entre les sociétés civiles,
entre les gens, entre les régions, entre les villes,
entre les municipalités,
c'est quelque chose qui...
Qui peut améliorer le climat.
Même si, je dois le dire,
les relations franco-russes, aujourd'hui,
restent toujours
très bonnes
et heum.
Nous sommes toujours des partenaires.
Nous continuons ces dialogues à tous les niveaux.
Et c'est très important.
- Alors la dernière question : conseil pour les jeunes générations ?
Si vous deviez laisser une bouteille à la mer
sur internet ?
- Oui
- Au jeunes qui nous regardent
Ecoutez, là je pense que
les jeunes
à qui appartient l'avenir de
notre planète, à qui appartient
l'avenir de l'Europe,
doivent être responsables.
Doivent bien calculer
toutes leurs démarches.
Et vraiment, c'est une leçon pour nous tous.
Il faut calculer les résultats de vos actions.
On parle de la politique extérieure aujourd'hui.
Donc, si on parle de la politique extérieure,
les dernières décennies ont démontré
combien il est important de calculer ce que vous faites.
Voilà.
La Libye.
Un exemple
très récent et à la fois
flagrant pour moi.
On a aidé à renverser la dictature de
Kadhafi,
on a eu comme résultat
le chaos
les pertes humaines
la paupérisation de la population
la destruction du pays
la défragmentation du pays.
Voilà. Donc, il faut bien calculer ce que vous faites.
Et dans votre vie privée
et dans votre vie professionnelle.
- Artem Studennikov merci.
Avant de terminer cette interview,
c'est un jour un peu particulier,
c'est la saint Serges aujourd'hui
et donc je voudrais souhaiter
bonne fête à tous les Serges.
Et je vous remercie d'être venu aussi vite
et notre communauté vous remercie.
Merci beaucoup et je connais un Serges
que nous connaissons tous les deux,
je vais lui transmettre
votre message.
- Merci beaucoup.
- Merci.